i know it could be a multiple of things
but like what continues to be
the best way for you to build that
client side the best client development
strategy
is just delivering incredible
experiences for every single person that
you speak to
whether that's giving no feedback to a
candidate make sure it's the most
relevant and best feedback that you can
give them that helps them moving forward
because that person you never know who
they
may know or they could become themselves
so it's probably away from the usual
answer of
videos cold calling referrals kind of
referrals but
if that when you first start in your
recruitment career those first 18 months
are absolutely key
because you're speaking to so many
different people that
will be in your network there's probably
key decision makers
within a matter of years it's like what
can you do to warm up that cold core
i think you've got to be clever with it
um and i think what recruitment probably
does need to do
and it started to do it is treat itself
we've always said recruitment is sales
but there's a lot of things that recruit
the sales people do that recruiters
don't necessarily do so to give you an
example i think you need to be clever
with your outreach because different
things will work for different people